talk to me if you would as the uh uk's
defense secretary how did you feel
as you witnessed the scenes um
yesterday in kabul um
through strategic patience the taliban
has won this war
well i think you know as i
both spoke to you last week and indeed
in the
article i wrote for the son of telegraph
look i i think we all saw that and felt
a real sense of sadness uh that
uh first of all the forces that the
british and the international community
had invested in had melted away in some
areas so quickly i i think it was always
the lessons that you know i felt
incredibly important is that you you
don't fix things overnight in in global
issues you have to
manage them and uh you know ultimately
as i've said a number of times publicly
when when that deal was done a few years
ago what happened was ultimately we
undermined you know the the community
the deal undermined the afghan
government and left it in a place that
ultimately saw the end and the end is
always
i'm afraid you know the river flows
faster towards the end and that that is
what we saw yesterday and it's what
we're seeing in our pictures today but
you know my job as event secretary is to
make sure that we protect uh not only
the uk nationals but those afghans they
have an obligation to that is actually
why we're in the country the last few
weeks we've been in the country solely
to process those people
and to make sure we protect our
officials doing that job and we'll
continue to do so
so you acknowledge that the taliban has
won the war
i don't know how to win i think i
acknowledge that the taliban are in
control of the country i mean it you
don't have to be a political scientist
to spot that to where we're at
and you know i have engaged through a
third country yesterday to make sure we
seek assurances from the taliban to
protect our people and indeed the people
we're trying to work to get out
and you don't have to be a political
scientist to figure out whether or not
nato can regroup and go back to take
over kabul again i'm guessing at this
stage that's not on the cuts
no i look that's not on the cards that
that we're going to go back if you
remember at his height over a hundred
thousand troops were deployed
into afghanistan to hold the line that
wasn't just the initial obviously 2001
2002 intervention that was you know
almost a decade later
heavy heavy fighting
and i think you know the united states
has made itself clear that they're not
intending uh to stay and as the
framework nation uh that leaves us with
difficult choices and uh you know i've
been
pretty much honest about that all the
way through this process and actually
why as i said our defense strategy our
defense reform program that we put in
place back in march is designed so that
we're no longer so dependent on one
power or the other it's why we are a
record funding settlement so that in
future should something like this happen
again we can find it easier to find
international partners to to remain
okay okay we are where we are um you're
drawing up plans for an airlift britain
is set to evacuate its citizens um talk
to me about the logistics as best you
can how many people are we talking about
how long is it going to take and when
will it start
so it started already only yesterday uh
nearly 300 people came back
we
i've just been like you seeing the
footage of the airport that's been going
on at the moment the military side of
the airport so the footage you're seeing
is from the south side the civilian side
the military side of the airport is
secure
and controlled and military flights are
coming in and out and i think
on friday when i spoke to you i told you
we had a plan b which was if civilian
flights stop we we will use military
flights that is what we're doing the
military flights are coming in and out
they've just brought in more uk soldiers
border force is joining us to make sure
that we accelerate the process to get
more afghans out which is our obligation
we we flew out
370 staff
and british citizens eligible personnel
yesterday and the day before and we'll
continue to engage those flights uh the
next group of afghans to come out will
be 782
and we'll make sure we get them in the
next 24 to 36 hours out of the country
and i'll continue to process those
people how many emergency visas can we
process for those who risk their lives
for the uk in the in the time that's
left
well we've processed over 2 000 plus
since april with their families and
they're all back in the uk located with
their families and myself in the home
secretary i spoke to her all through
yesterday and i'll continue to speak to
her today we are processing as fast as
we can and where there are sort of
rules that we need to change we are
changing those rules and so today i'll
be speaking to pretty patel about how we
can deal with afghan passports right up
until day before yesterday the afghans
wouldn't let afghans leave without their
passport
if if they've already been through our
checks we know who they are we need to
see if we can uh make sure that we adapt
the rules to get those people out as
soon as we can and we will cycle them
out from afghanistan to a middle east
country and then back to the united
kingdom so we can keep the flow of
airplanes in and out and
our target is at least 15 about 1200 to
1500 exit a day in the capacity of our
airplanes
and we'll keep that flowing and we've
secured a place
within the airport that we can process
people securely and then marshal them
onto the planes 2000 is not enough there
is as far as the interpreters are
concerned are we are we processing many
more than that at the moment given the
situation that is developing and
some have already been killed others
surely will be
yeah so
first of all it's not just interpreters
it's it's public facing roles and any
even essential non-public function roles
it's also contractors uh we again a few
weeks ago pretty patel and i changed the
rules to make sure third-party
contractors were able to come through
because that was important and then also
third country processing there are there
are a significant number who've got
themselves out of africa afghanistan
over the last few weeks and they are in
camps of refugee camps around the world
we bought a guy back in april as long as
he from april and his family from from a
greek refugee camp we're going to be
processing them wherever they are and
we're going to continue to do that after
we've gone but but you know you're right
kay it's really important for us these
are people
you know i've been as blunt as i can
saying that we will do everything we can
to bring as many people out as possible
and our soldiers that the 600 we've
flown in from 16 era saw brigade they
are on the ground specifically and for
only one job which is the processing of
british citizens and afghans to bring
them back we're not there for any other
government function that's what what
those men and women are now risking
their lives to do and quite rightly so
that is our obligation and we will do
that for as long as we can
yeah um the taliban has other ideas the
spokesperson suhil shaheen saying we
need all afghans to stay we're saying
we need those that are fought side by
side with us or represented us in some
other way can come back to the uk
that sounds like a bit of a standoff how
are we going to fix that
well i i spoke to a middle east country
yesterday who contacted the taliban
on my behalf the military leadership of
the taliban to seek assurances and the
assurance i got back from that
leadership was that these people would
not be
interfered with and that
they wanted to demonstrate that people
could come and go to afghanistan
as freely as possible and and that have
also you know that they obviously want
western troops out of their country so
it's not in their interest to
impede all of that and we will make sure
that we continue to do that
um last time the taliban was in charge
41 000 people sought asylum in the
united kingdom from afghanistan how many
asylum seekers are we expecting this
time
i i don't know but i suspect we will see
significant migrant plays around the
world um you know i you know my turkish
counterpart is dealing with significant
inflows i know that the iranians
historically usually take huge amounts
of refugees pakistan and india
as well and and i think you know it
it's not a comfort to this situation but
back in march when we did our defense
reform paper you know i recognize that
conflict prevention
and post-conflict uh work is as
important as war fighting because the
the threat to our stability from migrant
flows organized crime smuggling
terrorism is very very important we have
to be out around the world to deliver
that stability and so
we can expect at least as many this time
can't we well i'm not going to put a
figure on it
if the taliban are true to the words
that you've also read out on your
program about
an inclusive islamic state but
nevertheless
well i i certainly think they will not
miss the lesson of 2011 that hosting
terrorists and indeed
running a state as they did led to
rampant poverty
migration immigration or refugee crises
and indeed the toppling of that regime
those are facts that happened 20 years
ago
and certainly the political uh
leadership of the taliban recognized
that so
you know
on that sense the onus is on on them to
do that and so in the meantime i am
focused about getting those people out
those brits out as afghans out and
actually working together with our
allies you know whether it's turkey or
whether it's qatar or whether it's other
middle east countries uh to make sure
that we help stabilize the situation um
yeah i we are already hearing of
executions of those who worked with the
nato forces women literally being turned
away from their places of learning
it doesn't look um anecdotally as though
the taliban has changed much
lately no that does not look like a
change um and i think
uh we have to make sure that the taliban
leadership lead their country and uh you
know if there are
provinces or groups that are behaving
like that
you know that both the european union
the united
kingdom and the usa have been very clear
that you know the leadership has a
responsibility uh to make sure that it
upholds human rights uh as does the
quran actually the the koran does not uh
uh accept many of these things and that
is a wrongful interpretation of the
quran so i think i think that it's
really really important that the taliban
recognize they're on display now the
international community is watching they
want the finances they want the flow of
money they want the aid
they want to be accepted
as a
national leadership then they're going
to have to deliver that how prepared are
you for the taliban flag to be flying
over the uk embassy in kabul
well
that's the consequence of the taliban
it's not the embassy anymore we have
left that location we've drawn down
within the airport as has a member of
other nations many of the eu have
relocated so it's now just a building uh
but uh you know
in the end of the day
yeah
symbolically uh it's not what any of us
wanted
okay will you recognize the taliban as
the government of afghanistan
i think there is a lot of more to come
before those decisions are made i think
i think the taliban have to match their
words with what they say
i think the time is not right yet uh the
proof of the pudding will be obviously
in their actions rather than their
rhetoric
okay how frustrated were you that the
foreign secretary was on holiday abroad
when all this was unfolding
genuinely i don't know where he was or
as in whether it's cyprus i believe
okay i i don't know his uh my colleagues
personal movements what i do know is
every single day i spoke to foreign
secretary every day i had no problems
nor did the prime minister or anyone
else engaging with the foreign office
the foreign office has been in lockstep
with the mod who have been at the
forefront of delivering this alongside
the home office
so uh you know i have not been aware of
any drop in service or inability to
deliver the whole of government has been
tasked on this the prime minister uh
convened his first cobra a few days ago
and the second one yesterday and we're
all determined to deliver the solution
can we end where we started please the
taliban are not known to be patient
except potentially uh these last two
decades when they wanted to take back
their country they certainly seem to
have managed that over the last 24 hours
they won't
take too long before they decide that
they want the airport back we have a
finite amount of time to get brits and
those who help the brits out what's your
time scale
well our declared time style was by the
end of the month and the first week of
september but recognizing exactly what
you say
we are doing everything and we'll be
doing it today to remove any further
barriers to make sure we can rush
through both afghans and british
citizens uh to make sure that we can
process them and get out the country as
soon as possible by the end of the month
well that was our original timetable and
but i recognize as the facts on the
ground trained k we have to change too
which is why the home sector and i have
been working absolutely in hand in hand
in the last few weeks to make sure we
remove those barriers the prime minister
the chancellor be incredibly supportive
in delivering that and we will move on
we have to move about move regulations
today we'll be doing exactly that